[Music]
six years old these are girls already
sold into marriage many too young to
even know their own ages
six years the husbands they'll go to are
a decade or more older the last to talk
is five years old
the youngest in her father's arms is a
seven-month-old baby given in lieu of
medical bills
the girls have no say
this in one of afghanistan's poorest
villages
and the deprivation here means girls are
being sold into marriage earlier and
more often
there's not enough room in the tent for
all the parents who want to show us
their young daughters they've sold
we don't want to sell them she says but
we're poor and we have to eat
hajira had fetched an above average
price more than six thousand dollars
then she got injured and the deal was
called off
had already sold her to a family her
father tells us but they brought her
back when she got injured and said they
couldn't take care of her so i never got
any of the money
now he's on the hunt for another buyer
once final payments made for his eldest
daughter she'll be sent to her new
family she wants to study and is too
young to question what's happening
[Music]
my father told me because we're poor she
tells us
that's what we're told time and again
and in this remote village it was hard
to find anyone who hadn't sold their
little girls as payment in kind to
settle debts or just to buy food
some of the villagers are now living in
tents after an earthquake a few days
earlier which has reduced to rubble what
little they had you can see
all the house has fallen down all the
exterior walls have fallen down and the
two children sleeping there died these
people were struggling before but nearly
six months after the taliban took
control the country's economy is
collapsing
and those like gulsha who thought life
couldn't get any harder are telling us
it can and just has
she sold her two-year-old girl satera
who she was still breastfeeding her
family was so desperate
with no food no water and lots of others
to feed she says what mother wants to
sell their children but there's no other
solution
the baby was returned because she
wouldn't stop crying but the family who
bought her say they'll be back when
she's a bit older
now gulsha is trying to find buyers for
her two other girls
and she's not alone the extreme poverty
across afghanistan has led to an upsurge
in early or forced marriages for money
they've all pretty much sold daughters
in this deprived region girls are
reduced to possessions to be bartered
over
the remote villages in this corner of
badgis are very conservative and very
underdeveloped
and they've long been strongholds of
taliban support
but the taliban commanders and elders
here told us
they want the international community
back
not the military but the foreigners help
so he's happy to see international
people back in afghanistan again
we want the international community to
come to afghanistan to help us the
commander tells us and since the taliban
came to power there's no security
problem for anyone and we assure all the
foreigners about this in the future
but right now the humanitarian crisis is
hitting the country hard and
afghanistan's daughters are amongst
those suffering most
alex crawford sky news in caddis in
north west afghanistan